we
yes so good morning and welcome to Bo
thanks so many of you out day
again apies
apologies from councelor Heather
Fairfield chair of this meeting Gareth
James I'm the deputy Place lead and vice
chair of the health and wellbeing
board morning everyone Tom Malone
program director across health and care
for the council and local NHS
GMT morning everybody Richard sping
managing director Trafford local Care
Organization and I'm here for Casey calv
Thomas who Chief
exective morning all Jamie Le head of
leisure traffic
Council hello um Council Karina Carter
executive member for children young
people morning everybody I'm Jill
McGregor I'm the corporate director for
children's services here in
Trafford hello everyone SAR Chief execu
Council and place lead for Trafford as
well morning uh Richard Ro corporate
director for play
Council hello I'm Liz Cen director of
strategy at greater Manchester mental
health hi I'm Caroline sidol I'm the
housing strategy and growth manager at
the
council hi I'm Matthew Fus the
operations manager from the African
Caribbean Care Group doy EV sends her
apologies hi I'm Jean RH from
healthwatch Trafford I'm uh in place of
Heather Fairfield
today poor Rogers Democratic
Services uh George Devin from Trafford
Community Collective representing the
volunteer community fa and social
Enterprise sector in
Trafford Good morning Joe Cher CH it's
Trafford
Leisure hi I'm Jane wearing Clinical
Director Trafford West PCN represented
GP board
morning Jane Hines public health program
manager of traffic
Council I'm mother Jane I'm councelor
Jane broy I represent tley but I'm here
as one of the LI Dem reps I
believe morning everybody Liz Murphy the
independent chair and scrutineer for the
traffic Safeguard in
Partnership good morning everyone mayor
Nathan Atkinson I'm the corporate
director for aults and wellbeing and
traffic
outs
thank
you thank you and I think we yeah we
have got a Jane overload uh this morning
I know that we've had the a Sarah ones
as well in the past so and I've been
told that we've got a few more people in
public health so it looks like we're
going to have a Katherine and Katie one
in there as well so thank you everybody
um so if we can just look at the uh
minutes from the last meeting can they
be agreed as is a true
reflection are there any matters arising
from the minutes that we haven't got on
the
agenda no thank you everybody and um if
there are any Declarations of
Interest
Jane um I work at with andure hospital
as part of mft thank
you no further declarations thank you um
I have no uh key messages for
considerations so if we can move on did
you have some at Paul think not okay
thank you um any any urgent business um
that I haven't um already been told of
that's on the agenda here don't know if
my agenda's back to front I'll have a
look at what I've got on this on the
computer as opposed to what I've got on
the
paper yes uh so if we can now move on to
item six which is over to you Jan for um
physical act inactivity thank
you
spe
um so using the next set slid just
wanted to discuss the progress made
since a deep dive into the physical
activity um into the deep dive into the
physical activity back in July of
2022 um the presentation will Echo the
report that's been circulated we've got
three key priorities that we've agreed I
won't read them out in full but just as
a snapshot produce a data set to enable
a strategic planning and
prioritization two is about using
physical activity and sight to support
the production of place-based physical
activity plans and three is an
evidence-based approach to Neighborhood
active travel
plans so starting with Priority One what
we do have is really robust is Sport
England's active live survey so that
really gives us a platform and a rich
data set we can all stand over with
confidence and what's really good about
this year is that we've got a really
large sample size which a thousand
people so really good and it allows us
to get a bit more into the detail the
trends the themes and something that
I'll draw upon in the next couple of
slides um just for those that might not
know or just to reemphasize the point
being active for adult is defined as 150
minutes of moderate physical activity
per week as you can see in the green
there fairly active is from 30 minutes
to 149 and under 30 minutes is defined
as inactive and I think the first thing
to collectively celebrate is um around
this Ro is that adult activity in
traffic is at an alltime high and if I
had better presentation technology
skills would probably have that that
bullet point on the left flashing with
fireworks off it but it's something to
be really celebrated within Trafford um
I guess there's a flip side and another
side to that coin is that we still have
24% of Trafford that are inactive which
haven't recovered since the pandemic and
just to quantify that with the figures
at the bottom um that's 44,000 people
who are inactive and 25 ,000 of those
44,000 do nothing at all um what has
improved is that those that were fairly
active having the majority moved over to
become active so what you kind of
presented with is a bit of a
polarization where you know we do really
well with the active piece there's not
many sitting within that fairly active
piece but then we still have 44,000
people 24% are are
inactive so just going to delve into the
detail a little bit um as we can see
within the graph that there's key
demographics that have higher levels of
inactivity theyve come through this
active live survey as it presents for
Trafford it's those Asian and black
communities when we compare it to White
British and other um those are much more
inactive and what we can also see is
that there's a trend and it'll come
through with my next set of slides is
that position to worsen since the
pandemic again taking a look at this
that theme continues in terms of since
the pandemic when you look at the split
between demograph such of men and women
since Co men inactivity is reduced as
you can see is significantly coming down
but what stayed stagnant is women's
inactivity is still at
26% same theme with limiting
disabilities limiting illness or
disabilities um able-bodied have become
less inactive and that had a similar
trajectory for those with limitting
illness and disability but again since
the pandemic that's actually reversed
and it's now moving up to 43% of
inactivity
and again just to Echo the point it's
also with the least affluent as well we'
mentioned before when I bought traffic
moov into this board that inactivity is
linked to
deprivation um and this slide reinforces
that with two probably key points to
highlight one is people in lower social
economic groups are more inactive than
those in the higher groups and that Gap
is only growing as you can see from the
two blue lines as
well so that covers active live survey
which gives us a really platform and
starting point um but what the report
also draws on um is that we have a
number of other developing data sets to
paint a more detailed picture so we've
got traffic leisures operating agreement
we've got the holiday activities and
food program and we've also got travel
data sets as well another data set which
we draw in and this side pulls out is
the B well survey something that's
carried out by Manchester University
would support um and that breaks down
into our localities which is a guess is
really helpful for the audience that
we've got today and what that told us
when we looked at it is that children
young people when asked didn't that they
have good physical health as you can see
from there centrally
91% West 85 89 82 so a lot of children
young people think that they have good
physical health but that but the data
actually doesn't back this up and
actually not one of our localities has
over 50% of his children and young
people that are Physically Active for
more than an hour a day which is the
recommended um piece and that Trend and
that issue isn't just owned by Trafford
it's something that's shared across GM
as well so if there is a positive in
this it's only that the north the B is
the only one that falls below that GM
average so that wraps up sort of the
data set and approach to that in terms
of focusing moving into the priority two
and the production of place based
physical activity plans what I wanted to
show with this slide is that obviously
we know from previous presentations is a
traff mov it and a place based approach
is our umbrella strategy and our north
star guides everything that we do um but
there is no Silver Bullet I guess to a
place-based approach it's a collection
of approaches and programs that support
the outcomes that we're trying to
achieve I'm going to touch on Leisure
investment and active travel in the next
couple of slides and so Jan so I won't
label that a couple to draw on is
probably the holiday activities and food
program which hasn't been discussed
before um that is a is a program based
on targeting children and young people
um that are on free School meals in a
holiday period with activity and warm
food and has had real success in terms
of Engagement we've had 3,000 Primary
School um children take part we've had
over a thousand secondary school
children take part as well as over 500
SCD children so really pleased with the
outcome of that and what's also been
positive is we've been secure the
funding for next year as well the want
to labor is probably UK shared
prosperity fund again with working with
GMC um combined Authority that's been
confirmed um and we will be able to
introduce outdoor gyms in localities
where in activity is highest that's
three localities what we've also been
successful is drawing down
um um a delivery fund alongside that
which allows draffa Leisure to go out
into the community engage get more
people more active build social capital
in those areas as well so really happy
and positive with
that
um what we also wanted to do is include
this slide to remind all I'm sure
everyone's off fa with the slide is that
our place-based approach dovetails that
of the neighborhood program both work
with communities both draw on local data
and insight and support by local
stakeholders so there is a full
alignment at a local level with the work
going on across the two pieces of
work and this next slide just emphasizes
that connection I think this slide gives
us a bit more detail on the move more
Partnerships as I mentioned before
traffic moving takes on that targeted
Place Bas approach we go into a bit more
of the granular detail rather than the
localities we focus on seven specific
communities that are listed there and
those with the highest inactivity and
deprivation we focus on trying to get
those from inactive to fairly active as
that data set from sporting and supports
that approach as well we recognize each
Community is different so what works in
Parkington what work in Al Trafford what
works in broomwood what work in
stretford or sale more so we have to
take an bespoke approach which takes
more time and more resar and our first
plan has been really successfully
implemented in broomwood alongside the
neighborhood teams um that's that's in
place now and what we'll do is we'll
take some test and learn from that and
that gives us a platform again to roll
out across the other seven
communities so underpinning as I
mentioned before traa moving and the
place based approach is the council's
investment into the local Leisure estate
um I know I brought this to the board
before so um I'll use this as a snapshot
of where we're up to and an update since
we last spoke So alram currently closed
and due to reopen in the Autumn of this
year with a full refurbishment but which
really excited and working towards that
opening stretford um and one I wanted to
highlight in this for for stretford the
current scheme is in a preconstruction
phase but what we have with Stratford is
we have a real opportunity to reduce
Health inequalities for traford
the center and the design as currently
proposed is focused on outcomes that
support that local community and
includes things like an urban Cricket
Center and a really Community focused
program I guess what the collective
challenge is is meeting that aspiration
with the current budget pressures that
we
face for Partington we grabbed the
opportunity that set stretford has
through the leveling up fund um and that
is making good progress now bringing
Health wellbeing in a Leisure closer
together what we also have been
successful in achieving is an extension
previously due to be completed by March
2025 we have an extension to March 2026
which is great news um and then lastly
Old Trafford Sports B based in Old
Trafford as you can imagine um we're
working through the options of a
Community Asset transfer and that one
again focusing on the outcomes for those
local
residents and then operating agreement I
think alongside invest and alongside
significant investment is we need a
robust operating agreement with traffic
Leisure which is really important for
both it brings Clarity and it brings
confidence to everyone involved whether
that's the community stakeholders or
wider funders it has clear Focus for us
on health and wellbeing outcomes with
ongoing collaboration from public health
colleagues as well as traffic Leisure
and again we're using bespoke outcomes
and kpis to support that place-based
approach so that wraps
Priority One and priority two I'll hand
over to Jane for for priority three
thanks Jamie so uh priority three was
around those neighborhood active travel
plans um and similar to the place-based
activity plans we've spent quite a bit
of time getting the infrastructure and
the building blocks behind that um set
so we've got a good uh Foundation to
build from so we've got a walking
wheeling and Cycling group established
which is uh cross the council and wider
partners establish that internal
governance in terms of uh reporting and
where that goes through so in the future
there will be some specific walking
wheeling and cycling um highlight
reports that will be shared with health
and well-being board as well we've um
developed terms of reference for our
walking wheeling and cycling Forum so
that's enabling our residents to have
their say and put forward their views in
terms of priorities and how we um how we
work to deliver not just the the
physical infrastructure Network strategy
but also some of the support that goes
around that to enable people and support
people to walk with and cycle more and
Achieve that mode shift from uh from uh
Movement by vehicle to Movement by uh
our own steam um the group the first
thing the group has done is look at the
network strategy in terms of that
physical infrastructure we agreed a
prioritization tool and we've applied
that to existing schemes so these are
these are schemes that are funded for
feasibility design or Construction ction
so we've looked at how they um meet
priorities in terms of that strategic
transport network but also how they meet
priorities in terms of clean a in terms
of um lower levels of physical activity
things like low car ownership um and
also the next part of that is to look at
how we um ensure that they Link in with
our public transport Network as well
um we've got a strategic partnership
with the renew Hub so um basically any
bikes that get sent to the any of the
recycling centers the renew Hub anything
that's fixable the renew Hub will take
will fix up and we've now got a
strategic partnership so any um cycle
libraries that we um have funding for we
can actually get bike donations for
those so it's a really really great
partnership and it's again it's one of
those building blocks actually access to
a bike is one of the key barriers and
we've now got um a partial resolution to
that in terms of those bike donations um
one of the other kind of key parts of um
our active travel plans was around our
school streets offer um and the really
really positive is that we now have a a
dedicated School streets officer um
hosted by traffic Community Collective
um which has meant that our limited
resource internally isn't just working
on school streets but um Hannah who's in
post I think quite a few people will
have met and volunteered on school
streets with her is absolutely flying
and those are kind of it's it's one of
the suppose those kind of key baselines
in terms of those neighborhood active
travel plans is enabling children to
walk wheel or cycle to school
safely um and then one of our other kind
of successes in terms of that strategic
level is identifying funding streams to
enable us to deliver work in those
priority locations so alongside um any
of our highways infrastructure work
around active travel there's a dedicated
um budget for what they what tfgm called
activations work so we're now working
collectively to deliver that activation
and that's basically all that behavior
change work in terms of getting out into
communities supporting them finding out
what the barriers are to um active
travel and starting to overcome those so
that's been a a really positive way um
to actually get some of the um delivery
done in uh getting that um securing that
funding stream across the walking
wheeling and Cycling group so in terms
of specific outputs I um mentioned bye
cies earlier so tfdm have a number of
ground programs and Lizzy our walking
wheeling and cycling officer has worked
with local community groups and other
organizations to um establish where
priorities are linking in with that kind
of neighborhood approach and those um
place-based physical activity plans to
look at where we want to support
organizations and groups to apply for
that funding she supported um various
organizations to um be successful with
that funding has brought in about 90,000
into traffic
um through three bike libraries um cargo
bikes and adapted cycles and cycle
storage so whereas previously it was
very much down to individual
organizations who had the um the
knowledge the motivation to apply for
these grants we've now got that support
and we can look at where it really fits
in with our strategic um
priorities so bike libraries in stford s
West and flixton um we as I mentioned
before we've got our infrastructure
scheme prioritization so utilizing those
Trafford moving um focus areas alongside
key outcomes and strategic planning
priorities um we have our beat street
program Commission in stretford Old tra
and Old Trafford which um launches in
roughly A month's time um which is
supporting children young people to um
it's it's similar to Pokemon go every
child in a primary school in stretford
Old Trafford will get a card which they
can then tap on beat boxes around the
community to gain points for their
school and there are leaderboards there
are prizes aail able so it's a really
great engagement tool and it's those
Partnerships um that we've talked about
across um tfdm across the council um
from different departments that's
enabled us to bring together enough um
resource to be able to commission that
program alongside some match funding by
sport England so again it's really
focusing on those priority areas where
we know that there's poor air quality
and there's lower levels of
activity and then finally as Jamie
mentioned um broomwood moving is our
first place-based physical activity
partner partnership um and we're making
sure that we're linking our active
travel into there so the we're not just
talking about formal planned physical
activity we're talking about the
activity that we just do in getting
around in our daily lives and looking at
and working with that Community to say
well actually how do how do we get
around our community as well as um
moving for the sake of moving and doing
exercise okay Jamie am I carrying on now
yeah no problem we're very well prepared
honestly um so in terms of some of the
risks that we have with this program of
work we have got some limitations around
the compatibility of data that act to
accurately inform our work programs
we've had some really great data from
our active lives adults program we
didn't have enough data to tell us what
was going on with children and young
people hence the use of the um of the
bwell survey to try and pick up some of
that and so we've also got future data
sets that we want to bring in um bring
together but again we just have to look
at how um comparable those data sets are
so that we're not um not uh making
assumptions and drawing conclusions that
actually the data doesn't tell us um we
need to ensure that we engage our
community and our partners in shaping
those plans so broomwood has worked
really well we've got some really great
Partners but obviously there is the risk
that in other areas we might not get
such great engagement but um working
with our neighborhood leads and our
partners from the community Collective
hopefully reduce that um reduction in
capital investment obviously we know
that there's huge pressure on public
sector budgets and costs are still
increasing so in terms of that um
capital investment that's going to start
to get tighter um and the same applies
in terms of that exter external and GM
funding support active travel we're very
much reliant on the funding that comes
through um transport for great to
Manchester um and then finally we you
know the capacity of the stakeholders to
align these plans and deliver locally so
we're very much working collaboratively
across the system across our
neighborhood teams across Trafford leure
within the council butly we do have
fairly limited
capacity um so finally in terms of the
ask of the board is just to support the
next steps that are ident that we've
identified for each priority which is
set out in the accompanying report um
ensure that physical activity Sport and
Leisure is weaved into the refresh of
the locality plan um and advocate for
these plans through our wider
partnership and organizational
groups thank you thank you jam Jamie
that's been really informative so can we
agree those points that U those um next
steps yeah thank you and are there any
questions or comments anybody wants to
make I I I wanted to make a comment I
think that it'd be interesting to have a
look at some of the age profile of some
of I know we've looked at children and I
think some of where people start to fall
off doing exercise I'll be one of them
and if we can have a look around the
safety of women um exercising um because
obviously I know that that's quite um a
big concern for some women that they
don't want to be able to go out if it's
dark to go to to the gym and all those
kind of things so I think that if we can
have a look at how how people get do do
exercise safely that that would be
really helpful and and I can't wait to
start doing Beat the Streets with my
granddaughter she's seven and we're
really excited to start doing that so um
I think that would be great so
Gareth yeah yeah thanks really supporter
this really interested in this area so
my lots of thoughts and questions really
but I was just going to draw a link to
the Future AG agenda item Tom's going to
take around the refresh of our plans
locally and our intentions priorities
for next year so it's really important I
know we are we are working closely with
you and Helen and team to build it into
what we submit in terms of our plans for
next year as an ICB too but I think that
you know it's so important that this is
a constant throughout all of our plans
and it's going to be a real challenge
isn't it as we know with the context and
we'll talk about that a bit later but I
think it's so important that we do build
this in and really supportive of the
next stations
thanks councilor Bry thank you really
interesting great report good to see all
that work um James asked my question
about age so I don't need to ask that
one and um but my thoughts were see in
the presentation that one of the
challenges must be moving those inactive
people into the fairly active and then
moving them up because I can see a lot
of that work might just move the fairly
active into the active Branch but I'm
thinking drilling down on some of the
things Jane mentioned about age women
and sort of more evidence maybe on how
you'd get the very inactive people into
the next bracket and I'm wondering if
Jane mentioned about barriers and I'm
wondering if working with um health
professionals might be part of that
because sometimes if people are told by
a health professional you really must
exercise it can make a big difference
GPS and um you know from hospital visits
that type of thing if a medical person
says oh exercise will be a good part of
your treatment I think that that can
maybe be one of the things that might
change people's
approach am I okay to respond so um just
on both your questions around age in
terms of our traffic data I don't
imagine it's any different to the
National picture but we know there's a
big drop off post 65 and then again post
75 so yeah we're we're aware of of that
and need that's one of the things that
we need to reflect and in terms of your
question councelor broy on um health
professionals yes I think that is a
really good um routin and there's a
quite a few things which we didn't pick
up because they weren't specifically
related to the uh the Deep dive actions
but I can update you now so um working
with Trafford Leisure and tlco um we're
looking at a model that was done in the
south of England primar primarily to
reduce waiting lists for um physio um
services and and the like we're looking
at doing like a mass sort of triage
event um in our Leisure centers where
those where the physio teams will come
in they'll assess people where actually
moving more is the primary thing that
need to do they'll go straight to meet
the physical activity referral scheme
and other community providers who'll be
on site and they'll get straight started
straight away so that's just one example
of how we're um looking to address that
particular the first one in Partington
pleasure Center can of just add as well
in terms of you comment around inactive
fairly active and active I guess what
Trafford moving does as well is it focus
on the inactive specifically within
those seven communities because we know
that creates the big biggest it's the
biggest Behavior change to get those
from inactive because the generational
disengagement with physical activity
through to fairly active so the strategy
specifically focus on inactive and then
bringing in sort of the age drop offs
and then accommodating that each
Community is different trying to work
with a bport plan for each
area
Richard thank you actually Jamie said
some of what I was going to say anyway
so we are aligned which is positive um
so I think from the physical there's a
real Focus we have to prioritize the
resources we've got we've got limited
resources we can't prioritize we can't
do everything so we have to prioritize I
think you'll see from
the trap and moving strategy there's a
real focus on place and targeting those
places where we know there are higher
levels of inactivity the strategy is
built around inactivity which is why I
think we focused again on that uh in the
presentation you know we know we've got
good levels of activity um but let's
focus so it's not about getting those
who are active active more it is very
much FKS about those who are in active
and Trafford Leisure very much tied up
and embedded in this so we had Trafford
Le Bard away is it two weeks ago today a
week ago today it's all only a week ago
um today thinking about Trafford Leisure
priorities Trafford Leisure strategy how
that aligns with the Trafford moving
strategy going through exactly the same
data set that we've been through um here
and how Trafford Leisure can work to get
not just people into the leure Center
but working in the communities and
taking that really broad view of
activity this isn't about everybody
cycling this isn't about everybody um
running this is a really broad level of
people walking um people moving in the
chair moving at home um I know we had
colleagues um at scrutiny committee
earlier this week uh presenting around
allotments and again it's another way of
physical activities so really taking
that very broad view of what we mean by
physical activity because it can um it
can feel quite a barrier for people
doesn't it if you if we were were
suddenly expecting them to go out
running and doing 5K or 10K this is very
much about get off the bus and stop
earlier walk up the steps don't take the
lift if you're able to do that I'm
really on those small changes that that
that build up over
time thank you Richard any further
comments or questions no thank you and
look forward to hearing some updates at
Future boards it's it's a really good
really good report and you know it's
really welcome thank
you so if we can now move on um we're
over
to Tom for the locality vresh
plan thank
you
there we go
okay double check that works okay thank
you sorry about the delay there um so
really helpfully um this presentation
hopefully um lifts the conversation to a
more strategic level of how just one
perfect example of um tackling
inactivity fits within a wider locality
plan and set of um priorities for
Trafford as a system um now I'm
conscious some of these slides we have
included in previous packs that we
brought to the health and well-being
board but due to time constraints we
haven't necessarily had chance to go
through them in detail and allow a
really rich discussion which is what I'm
hoping for today from from Members um so
apologies that there might be a bit of
repetition from previous slides but
there are some some new detail in here
and really important to note that I know
there's some key colleagues in the room
who are fully fully involved in um in
creating um the locality plan refresh
that I'm about to talk about and
importantly the 2425 priorities for
Trafford locality um and to distinguish
between the two and I'll go into it a
little bit more detail as we work
through the
slides um we've spoken previously about
the aim that we want to create one plan
for Health and Care Within Trafford
Healthcare and well-being so it's about
integrating our existing locality plan
aspirations and how we refresh that and
the content within it um and our current
health and well-being strategy which
sits for obviously a 10-year period and
the rationale behind that there are a
number of key drivers for Change and I'm
going to draw what I think are the most
important pertinent drivers for change
shortly and but really wrapping that
around the core purpose of localities
within the new Health and Social care
model we have within greater Manchester
and that is about pinning our efforts
and resources and capacity around two in
in particular two missions of the
greater Manchester integrated care
partnership strategy which is around
stronger communities and helping people
stay well and detecting illness earlier
and if people recall they are
fundamental to the existing aspirations
of our locality plan that we wrote back
in
2019 people will be might be hopefully
will be familiar with this and I think
this is where Grace Manchester does
things differently than other areas um
that our model of Health and Social care
isn't one that's um mainly looked at
through an NHS lens but actually is that
preventive social model uh for Health
and Care and this really does resonate
with Trafford and the work that we have
done over the previous years since the
2019 locality plan and obviously the
health and well-being strategy so the
fact that this is front and center of
how we've refreshed a fiveyear strategy
in GM is really really uh important uh
uh for us within uh sorry to the side of
the strategy is a what's called a joint
forward plan and that contains 160
actions um obviously phased over a
period of time over the fiveyear life
course of the strategy but fundamental
to to the conversations I want us to
have here today is that that is baked
around the prevention and early
intervention framework um and we'll
probably touch on some of the cost
opportunities and the impact that we can
have if we invest in prevention at scale
um uh in our
locality we have a plethora of
strategies here's just a very very quick
screen uh quick screen grab of a number
there are in the table at the bottom you
can see there 16 plus strategies and
there are probably more that we could
reference I think really importantly
they drive our work this isn't about
creating something brand new and coming
up with lots of brand new priorities
it's about coalescing around the things
and the interdependencies that existed
within our existing action plans
associated ated with those strategies um
and building it around the strategy that
exists at greater Manchester
level we have now within our locality
and the recently published Before
Christmas GM operating model assess of
locality delegated responsibilities we
now know what they are the operating
model is still in it in its infancy and
some of the processes in governance
still needs to work its way through but
actually we're quite clear now on what
we're responsible for in the locality um
and I'll revert back to the previous
slide that's talked about stronger
communities and detecting illness
earlier that's where we can have the
biggest impact um on on ultimately the
aims um of the GM uh
strategy just to and I thought this
slide was actually a really helpful
slide because this starts to go into
some of the detail on the prevention
strategy that's contained um within the
joint forward plan and ultimately we
have a lot of existing work that wraps
around this we've just heard a fantastic
example of how we've gone through a deep
diet process we have the system working
in Partnership to tackle physical
inactivity and that's just one strand of
work that sits underneath the health and
well-being board and permeates through
all of our system governance but
actually we have a an opportunity here
to strengthen some of the roles of the
groups that we have we have um emerging
population Health Management approaches
which we're designing as a system which
will really Drive our work moving
forward um and we're in the process of
uh of strengthening our governance so we
have really clear accountability grip on
performance in some of our more thematic
groups around physical activity in
activity around tobacco and stopping
smoking etc etc um and the role that
this group plays in making sure we ader
and stick true to what is described here
within the prevention framework is
absolutely
fundamental I spoke very briefly about
the joint forward Plan before and and if
colleagues recall I think probably the
middle of last year June July time
we spoke about how that joint forward
plan had a number of actions in there
that actually we may need to strengthen
our approaches and our services here in
Trafford um to do the best that we
possibly can do and we did a very high
level analysis of where we might have
some gaps or areas for improvement and I
think one of the one of the drivers for
how we refresh our locality plan and
agree our priorities for next year is
about looking at what we're doing well
already and what we could be doing more
of within um the context of very f
challeng in financial times and capacity
constraints and but I just thought it'
be
worth bringing this back to the four and
concentrating on some of the things that
we would want to see as a health and
well-being board in next year's plans
and in the longer term refresh of our
locality
plan distilling all of that information
of which there is a lot I've tried to
draw out what I think of the key drivers
for change that will impact on what we
decide as a set of traffic priorities
for 2425 and what will make it onto the
longer term road map which will um align
with the time frame of the greater
Manchester integrated care partnership
strategy which is a fiveyear piece of
work so and I'll mention this in a
slightly bit more detail in the next
coming slides but our Trafford
commissioning intentions will obviously
help shape this I've mentioned on
numerous occasions the strategy and the
joint forward plan which should be um
helping curate our work and everything
pinning back to those we have an
existing health and well-being strategy
a very clear set of priorities that span
a multi-year program of work we have our
bottomup co-produced neighborhood plans
that colleagues in this room have been
driving over the last 12 months which is
that Community Le intelligence and data
that we use from our hubs um through our
lead Partners in the community
Collective and more importantly the
recent development of our neighborhood
networks that has to be a key driver for
what we concentrate our efforts on next
year um and I've mentioned the
prevention framework and some of the
analysis through what's called called
the Strategic Financial framework which
looks at the big cost opportunities we
have if we invest in prevention at scale
over a longer term period and obviously
we will have the NHS planning guidance
which still hasn't landed but as it does
um at the end of January hopefully to be
confirmed that will also obviously help
shape the work of our NHS
colleagues I've moved this slide just
slightly further up in the slide deck so
it does differ from probably the version
that's in the papers just because I
thought it fitted a little bit better
here and this is just to help us think
about as we embark on a longer term
piece of work to refresh our locality
plan how do we work um with with our
stakeholders how do we work with people
and communities of Trafford to ensure
that they have a voice in refreshing the
longer term aspirations that we want to
include within our locality plan and we
will use existing intelligence and we
have a plethora of intelligence and
really pleased to say that some of our
colleagues in the room have already been
sending through really rich intelligence
from reports and research that they have
done in recent times and and previous
times that are still relevant and that
again as I said before we'll really
inform what we H commit to over a longer
term period of time um so there is a
sort of a subtle ask within there around
is there any more intelligence that the
organizations represented in this room
can can help um share with us that'll
ultimately influence our plans moving
forward um and we have a small strategy
group that's been um created it's meta
two or three times now we continue to
meet on a three-week basis more than
welcome for people to join that
conversation as well moving forward so
there's an open invite there to join
that group um uh and help us with the
work as we move forward but one of the
key conversations we will be having in
the coming weeks and months about how we
communicate with people how we get
people's stories how that ultimately
affects what we decide to do uh and
concentrate our efforts and so
developing that co-production approach
co-design approach with an Associated
comms and handling plan so everyone gets
an opportunity to have a say um will be
really really important probably looking
at George and Richard here from a
neighborhood perspective is that the
neighborhood networks will be really
really pivotal in doing that and we have
those in each of our four neighborhoods
so that's a a fantastic asset to
use so that was locality plan refresh in
terms of the longer term and what I want
to just do now is walk through some of
the more recent developments in how as a
system a Trafford system we will develop
our priorities for 24 25 um which has
come around extremely quickly um with
some extremely tight uh deadlines as
well to to create what those plans are
so just to assure people we we have
started these conversations a lot
earlier in Greater Manchester this time
in terms of how we plan together for
2425 and and thereafter um and those
conversations have have been going on
for a number of months now probably
since the middle of last year and where
we find ourselves now is in a really
helpful place where we are looking at
I'm going to refer to the first bullet
point on the right hand side of the
screen which is commissioning intentions
so we're having conversations from an
integrated commissioning directorate
perspective looking at Public Health
looking at childrens looking at adults
looking at health and how those
commissioning intentions for 24 25 where
are the where are the parts where where
we coales on specific priorities where
we work in Partnership um and where
there may be some Divergence and how do
we work through that and and there is a
process to draft those commissioning
intentions probably by the middle of
next week and test with partners and
very helpfully um Manchester Foundation
trust and gmmh colleagues um are in the
process of sharing their intentions as
well so that we can really truly build
that in a in an integrated way the
second part of what is referred to as
the locality delivery portfolio is how
those commissioning intentions Elevate
and manifest themselves into a set of
strategic priorities for Trafford um
that both the locality board and very
importantly for today the health and
well-being board can own moving forward
for
2425 and distinguishing between the two
but also acknowledging there's probably
a set of priorities that touch both
boards um moving
forward and then the third element is
how we will um work together at scale
across 10 so the premise of coming
together as an integrated care board and
prior to that Devolution was how can we
do things once rather than 10 times and
benefit from doing so um so the dpls
along with d and DCS is and other key
people so directs of children sorry
using acronyms directs of children's
directs of adult social uh Services um
and the deputy Place base lead amongst
other colleagues obviously shaping maybe
one two three big ticket priorities that
all 10 localities will will um coales
around and with those things they will
be collated and that will inform what
ultimately is the greater Manchester
delivery plan for 24
25 there are don't tend to go through
lots of the detail here because some of
this actually isn't that relevant for
for for for this conversation here today
in this audience but um needless to say
this is all being done at relative pace
and with really welcome thoughts on how
the health and well-being board and its
priorities make their way into the final
cut that we put forward to greater
Manchester knowing that our priorities
have to be about holistic health care
and well-being not just looking at this
through an NHS l
um I've mentioned about the
commissioning intentions previously so I
won't dwell too much on on the slide
there but that does helpfully uh break
it down into the responsibilities of
each part of our system and how we're
going to bring all those different parts
of the system together to create that
one plan for GM but importantly one plan
for Trafford and our roles and
responsibilities last couple of slides
now um I did include this um and it
slightly left field but I thought it was
extremely important and particular
pertinent to the to the role and purpose
of the health and well-being board that
as we start to talk about what our
priorities are for next year it's has to
be fundamentally underpinned by these
five component parts so actually is what
we're doing is it evidence-based and and
evaluated do we know that it's going to
have the return on investment the
desired impact that we want or are we
actually picking things that we haven't
got that that research and evidence base
for and we know through previous convers
ation we know what works um so it's
really important that that stays I think
at the front of our minds as we have
these conversations um and that is akin
to the next one which is around a
population health approach which I know
Helen myself and lots of others in this
room are absolutely passionate about and
and a developing um along with the
support of the newly formed uh fairer
health for Trafford uh group as well
which will be looking at Health
inequalities
um this is a bit indicative at the
moment and lots of these dates May well
change but I just wanted to put
something visual on a screen that um
shared with you how we will run the two
processes and the time overarching time
frames for these so understanding that
we have a very clear um deadline by the
end of March probably a lot sooner than
that but February time to sign off our
plans for 2425 so we have a really um
system owned set of priorities that both
the locality board and health and
well-being board and its Associated
governance can really truly drive for
with but we also have the planned
refresh of the locality plan which will
take on board that longer time frame
that will give us that road map for the
next four years um uh in terms of what
we will do and there's some indicatives
as I said indicative time frames there
for um completion of the document and
we're looking towards a July
approximately time for the complete
refresh of that so further conversations
with the health and well-being board on
that longer term fre refresh are
obviously really welcome um for future
agenda
ERS hopefully that wasn't too complex
and it builds on some of the previous
short conversations we've had so I
wanted to just um open it up really and
allow for some really rich conversation
about um and we can just use these as
prompts and I'll leave them on the
screen about how we ensure that the
existing health and well-being strategy
is front and center of any plans that we
have moving forward um both 24 25 uh
priorities and the longer term um have
we missed anything is there anything
that we think we need to factor into
this process have we missed some key
drivers that we're not aware of um and
are there any gaps that we think we need
to um address or things that need to be
elevated to the top of a to-do list um
and then we mentioned the importance of
neighborhood networks and Community
intelligence and research from our Co
our colleagues in the room but how do we
ensure um that people's VI helps shape
our priorities moving forward both in
the short term uh 2425 and the longer
term and that those uh have that
positive impact on tackling Health
inequalities as we' spoke about here on
numerous occasions so I'll pause at that
point Thank You
chair thanks Tom that's really helpful
and I think that the slide that talks
about the drivers for change if we don't
get that bit right you know we aren't
going to be able to deliver what we need
to deliver going forward so I think that
that's U really important that it was in
there and I think that's what we need to
be focusing on and I think that you know
if people are interested in joining that
um group that you have if we can get an
email out to um uh health and wellbeing
board members to ask them if they would
be interested in joining I think we can
get some um flow from that I think that
that'd be really helpful and the point
that you made there just at the end
about people's voice I think that's
that's where we've got to be listening
isn't it you know you know we can all
have come up with these great ideas in
these kind of rooms but that doesn't
always translate does it to the person
on the street so I think that people's
wor I think we learned that through the
uh poverty truth commission I think that
those are the sort of things that we
need to be doing people's voice is
really important so thanks for that so
has anybody got any questions on com
Helen um I've got uh four things sorry
just writing notes as Tom was talking
one was just to say about the strength
of the commissioning intentions exercise
that we had this week and it was
bringing together um colleagues that
wouldn't typically talk about their
commissioning intentions together and I
think it was really powerful wasn't it
Tom so um colleagues in adults social
care for example were listening to the
ICB intentions and to public Health
intentions and it became quite clear
what our priorities were jointly and
individually and I don't think we've
ever done that before and I think it's
something we need to continue doing
because it was really helpful and really
practical at very basic level and just
also bringing together some of the
language so how adult social care talk
about something is sometimes different
than how health do and just having those
informal conversations just helped move
things on so that was the first thing
the second thing is around the health
and wellbeing priorities so our five
priorities um um alcohol mental health
physical activity tobacco and healthy
weight are all evidence-based drivers of
and contributors to poor health or
positive Health you know whichever way
you look at it glass all full half empty
but also there's a huge evidence space
behind each of those in terms of how we
work how we use our resources
effectively and how we measure outcomes
so Jane and Jamie's evidence around
physical activity the last presentation
we had around healthy weight and food
and we've seen that with our ncmp
results the year for our reception year
children so there is really strong
evidence around those we do Endeavor to
bring in the voice of our residents and
I think the work with the neighborhoods
has been a really positive example of
that where Public Health evidence
complemented what our neighborhoods are
saying so our priorities are
evidence-based but community-led so
that's worked really well and I think
again that's something we need to make
sure we bring into the locality plan
development and then finally I think
this will all be really complemented by
the fair health for all Trafford
approach so we've got our high level
priorities we have our locality plan
priorities um and then actually how do
we address the inequalities that sit
below both of these priorities so it
kind of ties it together nicely so that
that was just what I wanted to say
really um and obviously we love
evidence-based and cost Effectiveness
and everything else in public health
that's that's what we do so always you
know really positive in terms of the way
forward thanks
Tom thanks Helen I think that the point
that you made around um healthy weight
for our reception children and and the
that that information that's been coming
through and that change um in the weight
for those children is really positive
and it's you know down to all the hard
work that's been going on as part of
that process so thanks for bringing that
in and councelor
brofi yeah thank you for that update um
I understand the presentation we had
today was quite high level and sort of
top level strategic stuff but one thing
struck me that you said earlier on in
the presentation you said that when
you'd looked at the evidence in Trafford
there were some things in Trafford that
we did really well and there were some
things in Trafford that weren't going as
well as maybe we would hope but he
didn't say what those things are so I
wondered is there a report somewhere or
what are the things maybe that Trafford
need to improve on in terms of the the
plan that you've put together so I think
um what was probably referring to is in
the joint forward plan there's 160
actions associated with the six missions
of the integrated care partnership
strategy um some of those are evidently
driven and the responsibility of the
locality per se not not just health and
wellbeing board but all system partners
coming together and within there there
are some clear commitments from greater
manchesters to how localities will for
example upscale social prescribing using
that that's the one I always keep
mentioning because i' I've been involved
in that in the past um and so so um
there's probably more work we can do in
chafford around social prescribing
there's probably other areas within that
and I think it was if I quickly whiz
back I had pulled out some tangible
examples on one
slide bear with me there we go oh gone
too far way too
far there we go um so I think that
there's some listed here on the screen
which actually span not just missions
one one and two but there is more work
can do in some of these spaces we know
we have um some work in in training
Helen can speak more eloquently than I
can around vaccination and immunization
there are areas for improvement there um
as I said before around social
prescribing the creative Health agenda
and the arts and culture agenda that
contributes to better well-being um are
obviously um that the the commitment to
to the strategy Etc so I think there are
things that we we could do more it's
about how we prioritize that within the
constraints that we know we're working
working within so yes is the is the uh
is the answer we do have more detail we
do need to do more analysis though a
finer detail level than just the higher
level that we've pulled out out here so
that's part of the work the strategy
group and some task and finish groups
will will need to do over the coming
weeks and
months Richard do you want to come in on
that yeah I was just going to say you
know obviously if would it be possible
for you to uh reissue The Joint forward
plan so that health and wellbe board can
have a look at what our priorities are
hly I think it'd be helpful if we just
all refreshed ourselves on those thanks
Tom um Gareth and then you Richard if
that's all right I've got a
list and like heal Public Health likes
um statistics and stuff I like lists so
G's next thanks okay thanks chair and
thanks joh I'm really supportive of this
work and having a single plan it can
only be a good thing moving forward for
Trafford it just coming back to the
first first of the four sort of prompts
for discussion I think building health
and well-being board priorities and its
strategy into into our new refresh
locality plan is a fairly
straightforward piece of work and we are
working towards that single set of
priorities my concern is a bit of a
broken record is for next year and the
financial and performance context and
how we are able to move quickly on some
of the things that we know will have a
big impact sort of as the first year of
that refresh plan and strategy so so it
is very much about working differently
and being creative because you know
there isn't going to be the money to
invest in some of these areas which we
know is shortsighted because because it
will have a huge impact so it is about
working as this partnership you to do
things
differently um and creative So So the
plan fine for the commissioning
intentions I think although we're
working really well as Helen described
to to make that a single set I'm
concerned about our ability to move as
quickly if we want with some of these
things thanks
chair Richard thanks thanks right um
just a three quick points chair if
that's okay I just just a reflection
that um you know what a great platform
we've got now with the work we've done
on the neighborhood networks and that's
very different I think to the position
we were in a couple of years ago and I
would encourage colleagues if you're
able to to go to one of the network
meetings incredibly vibrant and I think
the work that George and public health
Team and the lco and partners have done
is is uh is really positive from our
point of view uh particularly linking in
with uh Mental Health primary care early
Health PS and so on so and I guess in
the in that context for us that the the
key challenge is the Public Finance
isn't it and what next year looks like
so we've really I think my suggestion
through here is um I'm sure Helen would
agree we need to be really obsessed
about the impact we're getting from from
our combined activity in this area so
not nothing gets wasted because we're
just not in a position to to do that now
are we and then I think the final thing
is is about local voices and we had a
really good discussion at the West
Network last week about that and
obviously the community sector do come
with the voices of local people uh and
it's really important that we put those
organizations at the center of that
which we are doing and then again with
the poverty truth commission as well I
think we've got a great opportunity
there uh I was there on Wednesday
talking about the integrated
neighborhood teams and the design
principles and the thing that I heard
back really clearly from the community
Commissioners was that actually being
treated with kindness and respect was
What mattered most to them we were
talking about all these other sort of
outcomes and public health things but
they actually said basically we want
people to be kind to us respectful help
us find our way around the system and
those are the things that will make the
most difference so I think when we
engage properly we get a better plan at
the end of it so I think we've we've got
some um we're in a really good position
with a lot of what we're doing at the
moment that's really helpful to bring
that person's you know people's voice
into that um Richard so thank you Nathan
do you wanna yeah it was just um really
there there's absolute opportune time I
think to to Really embed the health and
well-being strategies in the heart of
our plan and to be front and center um I
know the Manchester News picked up this
story but um GM IB colleagues have been
doing quite a lot of work into um the
the future future requirements um for
Health and Care um in in the city region
and building some of case for Change and
the case for change is showing an an
enormous deficit already 500 million
ever growing but you know if we don't
start investing in prevention in a
meaningful way and shifting resources
we're not going to see any traction on
that and I think we really need to
capitalize on that direction of travel
locally and traffic because there is as
Gareth rightly said and I share his
concerns um challenges with funding but
if we don't start shifting funding into
early intervention and prevention we are
starting up challenges whether it be
what increased weight in times and poor
performance um but also recognizing our
Workforce challenges and sadly that um
the population health is not um on an
upward trajectory across across the
region I in parts of traffic um so real
advocate for this and and absolutely
Echo Richard points about community
involvement and engagement I think we've
got some excellent examples in Trafford
and we really need to capitalize and
kind of mainstream that work in in
everything we do
really thanks Nathan and I think that it
really explains doesn't it why we need
to get the localy plan right for
Trafford and the linking to the fair of
Health for for all in Trafford I think
it's that's really the really big pieces
of work that we need to be making sure
that trafford's voice is always heard um
because you know we are different and
you know so we we we just need to be
seen um does anybody else George thank
you thanks thanks Tom thanks for the
report I suppose the area for me is that
that third Point around how do we make
sure that we're really focused around
Health inequalities um we know at a high
level you know whether it's the ICB
whether it's Trafford Council or any
organization within the system the
priority is always to reduce Health
inequality but I'm not sure that we
actually see that in some of the the the
delivery plans that the conversation
that we've had so far today is we've got
some really good evidence about where
the inequality is and we've got some
really good evidence about how we manage
and prevent that inequality so
suppose in terms of the question what I
would be interested in seeing is how are
we making sure that reduction in health
inequality and other inequalities is
featured in everything that we're doing
so I think that's a really good
opportunity for feeding that into the
fairer health for all and it makes it a
bit more real and it it kind of guides
our actions in terms of engaging with
communities supporting Community groups
and building from that community base
rather than maybe building from the
organizational
structure George really good point Tom's
gonna come back in thanks just Echo
everything that you said there George
and I do think the newly constructed
group mobilized group um will be really
pivotal in sort of holding our system
architecture to account to make sure
that what whatever we're doing we are
tackling Health inequalities I suppose
one of the challenges that we may have
along the lines is access to good
quality data to understand performance
both in terms of baselining but then in
terms of continuous Improvement and how
that performance um information fuels a
continuous Improvement approach that all
partners are involved in so I think
that's a that's a challenge that I think
we well accept and and it's well
understood but I think we need to we
need to probably work on some of that
and some of those issues around quality
and availability of data to inform the
work that we need to do um but
completely agree with what you were
saying thank
you thanks Tom and I think that once
we've um we've got that data and then we
have a look at where we are and we're
able to measure I think we need to be
saying you know saying very clearly this
is what we've improved on because I
think that sometimes we all know in the
in rooms like this where we can see the
changes but we just need to be letting
the public now as well so thank you and
thanks again and I'm glad we were able
to have a bit of a better debate I'm
sorry that the last few times I've had
to give you the hurry up so thank you to
so if we can now move on please to the
um item8 which is the better care fund
and that's going to be um a joint
between Gareth and Nathan I understand
so Nathan first yeah I think it'll
probably be me for this one so in in
terms of the paper you have in front of
you hopefully it's relatively um
self-explanatory um we have had um
through the various um submissions into
NHS England um Regular dialogue with our
our regional team and they have um
identified potential support um from an
organization called changeology which
they're offering to a range of areas are
H to ad not just ourselves um which is
five days um fully funded
consultancy um a lot of areas have kind
of put changeology on a a trajectory of
of Fairly run-of-the-mill activity um
but we feel in Trafford and having air
this this week at the the locality board
as well um that there is real Merit in
prioritizing and looking into work on on
our Intermediate Care and discharge to
assess offer through Ascot house um the
reason for focus on Ascot house is that
it has uh tripartite interest test
whether that be from the local Authority
um ICB but also um the lco as well um
and there are Financial um challenges as
well as um contractual and um delivery
model mechanisms which mean that we we
do need to look at a model that's been
in place for about seven years and
whether it needs a refreshing and
reorientation um so the aim from the
changeology work is to
provide an objective view on the the AIS
position but also what what a future
model might might look like and how how
we might need to uh to get there um
interestingly chain geology have gone
back to NHS England to ask for the
potential for more time to do this
proposal um which we really welcome
obviously um as a system um and we
should hear from them in the next week
also confirming that but at bare minimum
we will get the five days consultancy
work um this has been discussed at
length with with the various um Partners
um but obviously being linked to the
better care funds um it's only right
proper it comes to the health and
well-being board which is the the
governance framework for anything um
related to the better care fund um so
the reports here for noting today but
also for interested parties and that
includes colleagues from Health watch
and vge Community sector and members of
the public who also used the service um
to to be involved in in this piece of
work and we really welcome
that thanks na and I think we appreciate
the work that um
changeology are going to do for us it
just went out of my head then sorry they
going to do for us so thank thanks for
that does anybody have any questions or
comments around
no well thank you and can we um agree
those
recommendations yeah thank you so if we
uh move on now to the Joint strategic
needs assessment we're racing through
today so you're all it looks like you're
all gonna get some time
back
yeah well I know obviously because you
want spend a long time discussing with
Jo Sak is the highlight of the whole
meeting it's you know we love it well
it's incredibly important isn't it and
it's just it's it's um one of our
responsibilities as a health and wellbe
board sorry Tom and I would just I was
just sending Tom the presentation rather
than um so the my colleague Katherine
mallister who is our principal Public
Health intelligence lead should have
been presenting today but unfortunately
she's in well so um I apologize for a
bit of a clunky presentation but I'm
just going to go through her slides but
obviously I love data so this is really
exciting um I've sent you the slides on
email yes please thanks
Jane we put them all together so it
wasn't a clunky Handover but obviously
it's not work does
it best yeah exactly so just to say so
the Jo joint strategic needs assessment
so if we think about all the discussion
we just had a minute ago around
understanding our needs driving
improvement Health wellbeing requires
shared evidence for decision- making so
this week for example we talk the
serious violence needs assessment to the
CLT and had some really interesting kind
of outputs that perhaps changes the way
we view um some of the issues that
happen in Trafford and that is why good
quality needs based evidence is really
really important to ensure that we are
making the best use of our resources
that we're targeting these resources
where we need to Target the resources
particular particularly at the moment
given the financial circumstances in
public health we call that proportional
universalism um but yeah it's just it's
just more kind of Savvy targeting really
to get the best best bang for your book
and also um it allows us to measure and
monitor performance so as George said we
know what our inequalities are how do we
know we are actually making a collective
difference and that's really important
that's what a good needs assessment will
show us um so as a health and well-being
board I don't know whether you all know
this but we do have a statutory
responsibility to the Joint strategic
needs assessment and I've just heard
Jane's machine beep so I'm hoping it's
all right so if you go to the next slide
please Jane feel a bit chis Witter here
um um so just very very quickly I'm sure
you all know that need assessment is a
way of understanding which people in our
communities have needs so this isn't
about activity this isn't about people
who are going to service who are
presenting at GP practices who are
exercising through Trafford Leisure
these are people who have a clear need a
relevant of their activity within
service and the joint strateg need joint
strategic needs assessment is a specific
statutory requirement that a local
Authority must meet um and it comes
through the health and wellbeing board
so we have a collective responsibility
to ensure that we understand our needs
and that we are communicating and using
that evidence
effectively I won't read through this
I'm sure uh you read it when the slides
came out but this is the there's um such
Tre guidance on um the needs assessment
and health and wellbeing strategies but
you'll see there reducing inequalities
Health wellbeing current and future and
social care needs of our local
communities as well are all mentioned
within that guidance thanks Jan so some
of you will be familiar with this so we
do have a joint strategic needs
assessment which is led by public health
but we work closely with um colleagues
in the ICB to populate and colleagues
within our business intelligence unit as
well
um and if you click on if you go to the
Joint stre need assessment you'll see um
some kind of brief um descriptions
around our demographics our health and
wellbeing and specific population groups
so you can drill in further to
understand what the needs
are thanks Jame and just to to reiterate
why we do A needs assessment so we have
statutory requirements so we've just
done under the serus violence
Duty in partnership with um Richard's
team serious violence reduction needs
need assessment uh we do a domestic
abuse needs assessment which is
incredibly important and tells us uh you
know what what's happening in our
population but not just those people and
that's the important bit it's not just
those people coming through service to
that Iceberg kind of if you think about
that what we do see but actually what
the characteristics of our populations
and our communities tell us that we're
not seeing and why we need to commission
to address that and that's the that's
the pivotal bit for improving health and
then we have a responsibility around the
f pharmaceutical needs assessment Gareth
myself and other colleagues we attended
a meeting with our a pharmacy colleagues
last week to understand the changing
needs within our pharmacies at the
moment and then we have a responsibility
to communicate that and to make sure
that um all our services are aware of
access to and availability of Pharmacy
across Trafford it allows us to
understand our local populations inform
commissioning decisions which I think is
a really important point at the moment
given our resource and financial um
situation and indirectly to find out
what we don't know so actually you know
that un that seldom heard populations um
and also some of those behaviors that we
think are happening but actually aren't
happening and we you know build a lot of
kind of um discussion around that um so
very quickly how do we do A needs
assessment so um it's not a onep person
job and Kate will tell you it's not a
onep person job so at the moment we are
doing an Al and substance misuse needs
assessment which is really demonstrating
some really interesting information and
I can see Liz sat at the top and it
feeds into all the safeguarding stuff
but also into education um into planning
everything really um so we're bringing
all this data together and we plan to
bring it to the health and wellbeing
board um in a couple of months time but
really interesting stuff telling us
about what what we should know about
alcohol use and impact in Trafford and
also substance machine
so it requires topic expertise so we
work with the services Who deliver um
the experts Who deliver service method
expertise so it's that kind of research
base that understanding of the data and
intelligence and also that General
oversight to make sure we will be
delivering and generating
recommendations for action but it also
requires that leadership and interested
parties access to stakeholders because
we started the alcohol jsna with quite a
small group but now it is a standing
agenda at the alcohol partnership and
every alcohol partnership brings a
different kind of discussion around what
the data or what the needs are telling
us out in the
community but also um our stakeholders
might include uh the bcsf service users
Community representations professional
bodies and but it is that service user
and that Community voice that is
absolutely fundamental in a good needs
assessment um so how do we do a need
assessment um it should cover population
context so what type of needs what type
of settings outcomes so does our
population look like their national
population or is there something
different going on in Trafford so we
have to commission differently for
example and what are the changes over
time so we know our zero to five
population is changing it's becoming
smaller so that kind of um means that
when we're discussing our uh early
intervention and early years programs of
work we need to be thinking about those
changes but also how our population is
changing from North South East and C
East West and Central as well and they
are very different and that's incredibly
important I keep pointing at George
every time I mention communities and
populations sorry
George and time frames as well so the
needs assessment will tell us our
immediate picture what is happening at
this point in time with alcohol for
example or substance misuse but what is
that likely to look like when our young
adults who are using alcohol now become
uh parents of the future as well or a
key one I think and it's one that we are
really focusing on in public health at
the moment is thinking about our aging
population and what that means and how
we kind of think about that fragility
and um everything we need to commission
around
that so identifying our population so
just going back to that at the most
basic level it's people who have a need
and the people who don't have a need and
um the need assessment will just cover
those people who have that need so it's
stly obvious isn't it uh a bit overs
simplistic um but that's one of the
biggest time consuming bits of a need
assessment is getting that parameter
right at the very beginning thanks
Jane getting into a bit of the
technicalities now but kind of this just
explains that need versus activity and
often when we're in commissioning
settings we'll hear about data people
going through service but it's bigger A
needs assessment is about those who
aren't going through service who may be
going through service but are going
through the wrong Service as well so
they're not getting their needs M that
way thanks Jane and then um and then
considering the context so I've talked
about this it's like that shortterm
versus longterm simple versus complex so
if we go to the uh alcohol and substance
misuse we have people who use alcohol we
have people who use substances the
complex issues are those who use more
than one uh but also those people who
might use alcohol because of past trauma
because of mental health need you know
there's a lot of different contexts but
we also consider our protected
populations as well so Within A needs
assessment you'll see sections that look
at particularly uh people from LGBT
communities people from um our diverse
communities for example and consider
their needs to make sure that we are
meeting that need and then that feeds
into our Fair health for all approach we
also look at different settings and
population characteristics and across
the life course so it's all encompassing
as you can see a good needs assessment
is so in terms of opportunities and
benefits it helps us to understand what
we can commission and how to better
design our services look at changes in
the population over time to make it um
kind of prepare for that change um
potentially identify groups that are not
well served and that's really important
in terms of addressing our inequalities
and it helps us also identify where the
gaps are so going back to the alcohol
one at the moment but also the serious
violence one lots of discussions going
on throughout the process with our GMP
colleagues with our service colleagues
about can we collect this differently
can we change the way we record
characteristics and it's just taken me
back to the development day conversation
we had around traffic Leisure about are
we collecting the right characteristics
for our population to really understand
who needs to be who we need to be really
engaging traffic Leisure with so that's
this is kind of the the real purpose
behind A needs assessment thanks Jane So
challenges are collaborative buying so
it's that joint stuff so in public
health we're very good at getting our
heads down and and cracking on and
developing a need assessment but
actually we're not the subject expert in
an awful lot of these things we can do
the research we commission service in
certain areas but in terms of the
experience of our communities with
alcohol and substance misuse in Trafford
you know some of our services have a
real strong insight into that so the
joint is absolutely crucial it's about
the data the right level of geography
and I think there's there's a difference
between what our NHS colleagues can
access compared to what council
colleagues can access so we're fortunate
and that we have really strong
relationships with our ICB colleagues
but that really does reinforce why we
need to continue those
relationships a good needs assessment is
time consuming but the value is huge to
uh the way we work going
forward how we prioritize so that's one
of the questions for the board at the
end of this conversation is about what
do you want to see as a board and I'm
sure we will have lots of different
ideas of things that we want to do a
good solid needs assessment on but it's
kind of really with public health
leading we have the uh capacity probably
to do four really good needs assessment
each year and it's as a board what do we
want to see delivered and then it's just
the kind of Maintenance and upkeep on
existing so where we currently are for
2004 our existing jsas are the general
one that's on the portal so have a look
it's kind of just a top level uh review
we have a mental health needs assessment
which is currently just being looked at
to really um make sure is as inclusive
the pharmaceutical needs assessment so
that's a responsibility we have to
deliver that every three years and it's
a statutory responsibility of this board
we've just concluded the sexual health
one a health inequalities and a smoking
one as well and I think the comment that
Jane made about us sharing our
differences we make in inequalities we
need need to be better at sharing what
we find out from our jsas as well and
that's something that we are looking at
in public health ones that are in
progress silence silence serious
violence need assessment which is in its
kind of final draft stage I would say at
the moment and it's just going through
sign off and and will be published
shortly the alcohol and substance
misuses in the final throws we are in
the midst of an oral health one at the
moment um data is challenging around
that one so a lot of it is kind of
making assumptions from National
evidence around what the picture looks
like in Trafford um com uh looking at
the mental health one in terms of
combining it with some children young
people's evidence and just that General
jsna refresh there's a lot of activity
going
on thanks Jane So a forward plan is we
aim to develop a work plan uh for the
needs assessment activity and we wanted
health and wellbe board's engagement in
that to help us identify what we should
be doing as A needs assessment and how
we share the outcomes wider and how they
influence um how we commission and
redesign as as a
result um so questions for the board are
um what topic areas of practice does the
board consider might benefit from a need
assessment in the next 12 months uh
where is the greatest uncertainty about
population need in relation to Services
provided that's a tricky question how
should those topics be prioritized and
how do we make best use of insights
gained so over to the board thank
you thank you Helen uh it's really
interesting and when you look at some of
those um jsna assessments that are
already being done the information in
there is really really valuable and I
used to I like it when you can link into
the data lab and have a look at you know
which areas and you can look you can
drill down to ws and I think that's
really really helpful for us to have as
well so thanks for that does anybody
have any yeah Richard
first like your questions at the end it
looks like that sort Public Health exam
type question doesn't it think I might
be struggling with 2,000 words on that
Helen
um I
guess I think the the neighborhood
networks would be a good place to take
the information into where we've got it
split by four and it would be useful for
me I think to cross check what that is
saying with what the community sector
are saying they see and where the areas
that we want help in terms of the plans
that feels like the most useful uh
platform for us from from my point of
view
thanks yeah I I love Jon I have a bit of
a data geek myself and I think in terms
of the the value um not just in terms of
shaping your commissioning but also Al
just understanding your communities and
your
equalities um and I think it's on that
latter point that I think it it might be
interesting to taking on board Richard's
sort of um look into sub neighborhoods
within neighborhs recognizing that our
communities have changed in in the
census and we're more diverse and
Trafford than we ever have been in terms
of our communities
and are there particular communities
that maybe are under represented in our
kind of knowledge base and our
statistics um and just having that
greater understanding I
think thanks Nathan Richard oh sorry I
just thought of something else actually
I guess underneath all of this what we
do know is that we're not really
Shifting the dial in Trafford for some
of the hard to reach groups are we and I
think that would be the place for us to
go because it feels a bit as though so
we've done a lot of the easier part of
the work I'm not saying it is easy but
the heavy lifting Now is really in the
communities where we've got the greatest
need really so I think that would be the
other thing for
me
SAR I suppose just to I guess to
reinforce um uh Nathan's Point we've got
some absolutely fantastic data um Place
wise um way way more than we've had in a
long long long time but actually
communities of identity you know to
reinforce that point I think um you know
given the um enormous um change in um
ethnic diversity but also thinking about
people with
disabilities um and Beyond really as far
as the um uh proteced characteristics
groups are concerned I'd question
whether or not we need to be looking a
bit more closely there yeah thanks sir
thank
you thanks Helen it's just um from a
housing point of view I'll be Keen to
have some conversations about the
website the jsna section the Housing
section because we've recently done a
housing need and demand assessment and
there some lots of evidence and data in
there I think will be useful for that
section so um I have emailed the the
inbox but Kean to have those further
discussions about updating the housing
element of of the general jsna thanks K
thanks k
anybody
else oh oh sorry councelor bro it's just
a really quick question um because I
think one of the things you're asking us
is um around population needs and needs
that are unmet so I'm fairly sure
because this comes up a lot that when
you talk to communities and you talk to
groups you get the vocal people and you
get a lot of data from people who are
visible in the community but there are
like they're going back to the point
there those invisible people I'm
thinking people um long-term needs like
chronic fatigue um from covid and from
other conditions those that population
because I think Health watch did some
work a few years back on people who have
chronic fatigue they're are very Unocal
um unrepresented group that tend to be
just sort of invisible and they've got
huge need um so I'm just
wondering how you might kind of go about
finding out things about those groups
just aren't vocal and aren't
visible so we start by looking at
nationally published data and make it
not making soltions but looking at how
robust that evidence is and then
translating into what we would then
expect to see in a
population
sorry can't press a button clearly
Friday um I'm just saying we would start
by looking at the national evidence to
see what they're saying and how that
would then apply to a population um of
our demographics to see you know how
that kind of looked then but I think it
would come back to thinking about which
Services work with or know about people
who are experiencing chronic fatigue and
how we can then kind of work together to
to look at that evidence whether it's
through surveys or engagement or um
other population but it is that
initially with a good needs assessment
it is about scoping that issue before
you start then generating the data if
that makes sense but it would be line to
vcsc organizations who are supporting
people in the communities or um you know
commission Services as well to try to
understand the characteristics of the
population that they're supporting and
then overlaying that with that National
evidence or any other research to
identify other themes that come
through next Helen
Tom thanks chair um sorry again
extremely supportting work jsna for
nearing enough all all of my career um I
think it ties back to the conversation
we've just had on on curating a locality
plan um so I think this has to be
fundamental in driving the priorities um
stating the the obvious there are't I
but um it absolutely needs to to drive
those conversations that we're going to
be having over the coming weeks and
months
um Richard made a point about the
importance of of of data in helping
curate the the spoke neighborhood plans
that we've talked about
and we know that that's been a
fundamental focus of the neighborhood
Network so far um so I think that has to
continue that has to be continuous cycle
of of how we create priorities in each
of our four neighborhoods and sub
neighborhoods and then my my last point
is a is the third question so um I think
it's the
age-old
um issue that we have is that the
resources there are phenomenal they're
so insightful it's how we get every
layer of staff to use them and consider
them when we're thinking about new
Services changing Services um uh
decommissioning services in some cases
to to do things differently um so it's a
staff staff empowerment piece that needs
to wrap around the products because the
products on their own won't get used
unless we Empower people to use them in
a way um and interesting where I've
worked previously and there's been some
really interesting ways of how we've
done that and had staff Champions to
Champion jsna and and tie it in with
governance so nothing gets past certain
point without consideration of the
information that's contained within jsna
so there's probably some wraparound
structure we can processes we can put in
place to strengthen that and have to
help sounds really good I think it's
about that engaging the staff to do that
it's well part of your equality impact
assessment have we looked at the jsna
when we're doing those sort of things so
yeah I think it can become our everyday
language J saw you and then Richard if
that's okay yeah I was just going to say
it also works the other way around
sometimes so
if we decide on a priority in the
locality plan we can almost um create a
need say if we're going to identify lots
of people with diabetes they're going to
need that service so I think there's
something about um the needs being a bit
dependent on what what we're doing and
whether we're identifying that need in
people who didn't know they had a need
before because some someone met need is
people who can't get can't get a place
in the service but some of it is people
who didn't know they had a need until we
tell them so that kind of almost looking
at it the other way around to make sure
we're providing a service that we need
for people who have then identified as
needing it does that make sense yeah and
the identifying that need initially will
have come from A needs assessment
somewhere along the line that's
identified who's more likely to be
diabetic and not know that they're
diabetic so yeah so is it's a big circle
really isn't it and but it is about
using that intelligence to update what
we know about our population and where
perhaps although we've identified all
these people in this one particular
space what about the people in this
other area and yeah so it's just that
cycle of need
assessment I might just scrape through
um so I think the other thought for me
is just this a challenge for the partner
organizations here about how we put this
into our organizational plans and
perhaps we should have a health and
well-being board challenge around that
and just by way of an example we're
embarking on our community health
service plans and the shared plans that
we do with adult social care and in
those plans we've been working with the
public health Team and we're asking all
the teams that do the plans to evidence
their population health health
inequality impact in the work their
planning for next year and I think
that's the type of thing um that would
be really useful I know Leisure are
doing a lot of work on that as well and
I'm sure others are so that might be a
good challenge for us to share how we're
how we're doing it because it's all it's
very all very well Helen's team doing
the impact the assessments but it's what
we do about it that's the challenges
now totally agree thank you anybody else
no thank you so um thanks for your good
work and we look forward to other stuff
that's going to come forward for us to
be able to
uh get it into our everyday living and
language thanks thanks Helen
um has I haven't had any um any other
business notified to me but I did want
to put George on the spot because I
think that this may be George's um last
health and wellbeing board with us
before he goes on to uh better
endeavors so um thank you for everything
that you've done for us George and I
know that you know you're going to be
around in the future in in other roles
and and I'm sure that we will be tapping
into your experience but we would like
to thank you um if there's any anything
you want to say thank
you thanks for that
unexpected Spotlight Jane um I suppose
from the from my point of view and I
think from the the sector point of view
it's been really positive experience
these last three four years um and I
think the conversations that we have
really recognize the strength of the
sector and the capacity to build on what
happening in communities so it's really
thanks to everybody for supporting that
and enabling us to develop that kind of
approach in
traffic yeah I look forward to
continuing to be involved in whatever
happens to come
across my my way in the future thanks
thank you George you have been really
helpful
so no other
aobs nothing okay thank you you can all
have a bit of your lives back now thank
you
[Music]
e